[Musique]
la rivière est le bon exemple en
permanence de l'homme
[Musique]
je vous propose dans cette vidéo de
comprendre à quoi sert l'art nucléaire
dans la géopolitique mondiale génériques
[Musique]
pour maîtriser l'art nucléaire il faut
tout d'abord maîtriser deux choses il
faut maîtriser la chose nucléaire il y a
tout d'abord la fission ou la
destruction finalement ou le fait de
casser des noyaux d'atomes
principalement des atomes d'uranium ou
de plutonium en passant ces noyaux
d'uranium ou de plutonium
on libère une énergie incroyable une
bombe
reposant sur la fission nucléaire sera
appelée bond à pau bombe atomique
il y à un autre type technique c'est la
fusion nucléaire c'est-à-dire qu'au lieu
de casser des noyaux on va en créer
le fait de créer de nouvelles liaisons
atomique va dégager une énergie aussi
incroyable généralement on réalise la
fusion à partir de d'atomes d'hydrogène
qui vont former des éléments beaucoup
plus complexe et il faut aussi maîtriser
l'outil balistique
c'est à dire les missiles et les plates
formes qui permettent de les lancer soit
les lanceurs terrestre et sous marin ou
les porte avions
quels sont les effets de l' arme
nucléaire tout d'abord il y a un effet
de souffle c'est à dire que par
l'explosion
il va y avoir une onde de choc qui va se
propager qui va truire tout ce qui
existe dans un certain périmètre
il y a aussi un effet de chaleur 35 % de
l'énergie de l'explosion va être
transformée en chaleur sous forme d'un
fera vous et donc va brûler tout ce qui
existe dans un certain pays il y aura
aussi la création d'un courant
électrique qui va lui-même mettre hors
service l'ensemble des circuits
électromagnétiques que l'homme peut
utiliser on pourrait penser bien sûr aux
radiations et après cette explosion
nucléaire
mais dans un premier temps ce ne sont
pas elles qui causent le plus de dégâts
puisqu'elles vont s'appliquer là où les
fait souffler les faits chaleur nous
aurons déjà fait leurs effets mortels
par contre lorsque les différentes
poussière seront retombées
on aura l'existence de poussières
radioactives au sol qui elles vont être
très néfastes pour l'homme et pour les
êtres vivants
étant donné qu'une exposition trop
importante à des radiations va conduire
l'organisme a développé des
dysfonctionnements comme différents
cancers
la guerre froide c'est à dire le conflit
qui va suivre la seconde guerre mondiale
et qui oppose de manière non armés les
états unis et
l'union soviétique va reposer sur la
maîtrise de l'armé nucléaire
en effet chacun des deux grands
protagonistes etats-unis et union
soviétique dispose directement à la fin
de la seconde guerre mondiale de cette
arme les états unis via le projet
manhattan qui l'ont développé au cours
de la seconde guerre mondiale et l'union
soviétique en 1949
ils vont vraiment réalisé une course à
l'armement nucléaire d'autres puissances
vont également se doter de cet art
nucléaire le royaume uni acquiert l'arme
atomique en 1952 la france en 1960 et la
chine
en 1964 ces nations et d'autres vont se
mettre autour de la table car elle voit
la prolifération des armes nucléaires
comme une menace pour la survie de
l'espèce humaine et pour la pérennité de
la terre dès lors elles vons ratifier un
traité qui va endiguer le développement
de ses armes nucléaires
le traité de non-prolifération sera
ratifiée en 1968 ce traité n'est pas la
panacée étant donné que certaines
nations ne vont pas le signer comme le
pakistan l'inde et israël parce que ces
nations vont acquérir plus tard l'arme
nucléaire et d'autres vont quitter le
traiter comme la corée du nord en 2003
corée du nord évidemment qui poursuit un
programme visant à l'acquisition de
cette arme nucléaire
outre la puissance militaire qu'elle
confère à son détenteur l'arme nucléaire
évidemment est synonyme de puissance
les cinq premiers états qui détiennent
l'armé nucléaire vont faire partie du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu l'onu cette
grande organisation internationale qui
regroupe les différents états du monde
au sein de ce conseil de sécurité les
cinq premiers détenteurs de l'armé
nucléaire etats unis union soviétique
chine france et royaume uni vont
disposer d'un siège permanent au à dire
qu'ils sont membres à vie si on peut
dire de ce conseil
en plus d'être membre permanent ils ont
un droit de veto et donc peuvent
s'opposer à quelque décision que ce soit
prise par la majorité des autres membres
pour rappel le conseil de sécurité de
l'onu veille à la au maintien de la paix
et à la gestion des conflits à l'échelle
mondiale paradoxalement l'art nucléaire
peut être synonyme de paix en effet
l'art nucléaire permet ce qu'on appelle
la dit
sus à ions la dissuasion c'est un
principe un principe selon lequel celui
qui détient la nucléaire ne sera jamais
attaqué parce qu'il dissuade son
adversaire potentiel de l'attaqué au met
au coeur de la guerre froide lorsque les
états unis et l'union soviétique se font
face une aucun des deux protagonistes ne
souhaite attaquer l'autre parce que
s'ils attaquent l'autre l'autre
ripostent immédiatement et les deux sont
irrémédiablement détruits c'est le
principe de la dissuasion nucléaire
en ce sens l'arme nucléaire et donc une
assurance vie pour celui qui le détient
et c'est pour ça que de petits états se
dote de l'armé nucléaire
je vous propose maintenant deux outils
le premier outil proposé sa belle nuke
map
il simule une explosion nucléaire ici
j'ai pris comme point le centre de notre
école le jardin français et vous pouvez
sélectionner ici la charge de votre
bombe ou peut prendre aussi des bombes
célèbre entre guillemets
si on prend la bombe qui a frappé
hiroshima en 1945 on peut simuler la
détonation et vous voyez ici que
l'ensemble du domaine de la barrière est
totalement déjà irradiées au niveau des
radiations le centre videmment le choeur
de l'école tous les étangs tout a été
soufflé à la fois par l'effet de souffle
et est brûlé par l'effet thermique mais
on voit qu'il ya des dégâts jusque aux
environs du village là on est là sur un
bond de 15 kilotonnes
par contre nous allons simuler
l'explosion de la plus grande bon
qui existent la plus grande au monde luc
les airs du procès de bonds soviétique
darbo sans mégatonnes fait exploser et
là vous voyez que les dégâts sont
colossaux
puisque la moitié de la belgique et a
démenti du nord de la france
ce qui était intéressant c'est tout et
c'est que vous avez à chaque fois ici à
côté la description des dégâts vous
pouvez vraiment vous imaginez les effets
que tout cela pourrait produire
le deuxième outil est ici juste à côté
vous cliquez sur missiles bape et là il
s'agit plus de voir quelle est la portée
les différents missiles alors ce qui
nous intéresse particulièrement de
l'actualité du jour c'est la corée du
nord
donc on va prendre une base de lancement
nord-coréenne on va choisir un missile
le plus récent celui 2017 et vous voyez
ici est la corée du nord peut atteindre
l'entièreté des pays de l'hémisphère
nord sur une partie des états unis mais
voilà tout ce qui est en clair n'est pas
atteint par le missile tout le reste
peut être atteint par le missile
évidemment ça pas toujours été le cas si
je prends d'autres missiles nord-coréens
vous voyez que la porte et s'est
progressivement accru
[Musique]
jusqu'à les capacités actuelles
cette vidéo est fini je vous remercie
pour votre attention il reste les
commentaires si vous souhaitez apporter
des précisions ou si vous avez des
questions je vous remercie et j'espère
qu'on se retrouvera très bientôt sur
cette chaîne logée aux sociétés à très
bientôt
[Musique]
m